This fishing saucer lets you snag guppies
in a boat that looks like a flying saucer.
And never have a growl in your food trap again
as starvation is banished thanks to Moon Farms!
Vsauce!
Kevin here.
This is Noggin' Blow!
Buckle up motorists as a researcher at Volvo
has developed the three-point safety belt.
The fitting is next to the seat instead of
behind it and the new design allows you to
buckle using only one mitt.
Allowing you to safely cruise your can with
your sweetheart in style.
The Heli-Bout is half boat half helicopter.
Designed by Brook Stevens the blades on top
spin but don't actually lift the boat.
But act now because it features a motor with
75 horsepower.
Teach your baby to walk with wooden beams
and a harness!
There are now 486 hours of color television
programs.
And the RCA "Aldrich" Color TV featuring a
ridiculous 21 inch screen is now available
only $500 smackeroos!
($4,347.92 today)
Keep your keister on the couch and change
the television station with remote controls.
The Space Commander 600 features a revolutionary
four buttons - one to make the channel go
higher - one to make it go lower - one for
volume - and one for mute.
You can even adjust the hue to make the image
on your color boob tube more red or green.
Good news, homemakers introducing the refrigerator,
stove top, sink and storage cabinet all in
one!
Hula Hoop madness has begun!
Richard Knerr and Arthur "Spud" Melin evolved
Australian bamboo exercise hoops into 42 in
round hoop toys for girls and boys made with
Marlex plastic.
Marlex plastic!
I'm gonna leave you with a telephone answering
machine - and as always thank you for viewing
this audio visual presentation.